all right everybody let's jump into that
first story we got this one from the New
York Post Anheuser-Busch loses more than
five billion dollars in value amid Dylan
Mulvaney Bud Light controversy this
story is from just today so simply put
it's getting worse they say since March
31st shares of Bud light's parent
company have fallen by nearly four
percent knocking down the company's
market capitalization from 132.38
billion to
127.13 billion on Wednesday
Anheuser-Busch stock fizzled more than
1.5 percent on Wednesday so let's talk
about this because uh just before the
show Ian brought up that uh Joe Rogan on
his show said it wasn't a big deal or
something to that effect could you uh
could you elaborate on that email yeah
and I don't want to put words in
anybody's mouth but it was uh a clip
that was on YouTube from and I should
pull this up immediately was it recent
or was it yeah it's very recent he had a
comedian on by the name of oh come on
but it usually takes a couple days for
him to release the podcast though so
that's also something we should consider
here but exactly there's one with Sam
Talent uh Talent is like a Sam Talent is
a guy's name and really Sam was talking
about it when did it go up it went up
let's see six hours ago on you so I
imagine that was probably recorded
yesterday or Monday something like that
maybe yeah probably and I'll say I think
they're wrong about this they crack a
couple Bud Lights they're like yeah I
think the the drama's over and but you
were saying that you think maybe he's
he's insulated being on Spotify you guys
were they were drinking the beer yeah
they pulled out a couple of Bud Light
shows drinking in solidarity it had like
tongue-in-cheek but the Sam Talent is
like yo I love Bud light's great it's my
favorite beer you know how how could Bud
Light be someone's favorite beer I think
he said it was his favorite beer but I
just mean you could drink 20 of them
really you can drink like six of them
because they're not really hot they're
not really thick it's the fluoride and
the cost of uh calcifying of the pineal
gland that gets people addicted towards
destroying their their frequencies right
it's the kind of beer yes yes but it's
the kind of beer you drink if you just
want to get drunk and you don't really
care about the flavor as the joke goes
it's the kind of beer you drink when you
don't want to drink beer but you want to
drink a lot of it I thought that I
didn't write that I saw that on on
Reddit or something I thought it was
brilliant but I heard that Joe Rogan
cracked open a beer and they're like oh
it's no big deal and it's like you know
what I wonder about this uh I wonder if
you know when Joe was on YouTube more on
YouTube he could more see the direct
impact of his comments and and what
people thought about them and when
you're on Spotify and you're releasing
you know after the fact I think the last
time I went on the show it was like five
days later they released it and I think
it was before I went on before the
writtenhouse verdict and then he aired
it after the writtenhouse verdict so
that like really changed a lot of the
context but I think what happens then is
if you're not really paying attention
you don't see what people are talking
about you're like I don't know I saw
some people talking about this kid rock
did a thing but I guess no one cares
anymore and now it's several days later
you put up an episode and once again
anheuser-bush stock is going down people
still care about this and the
conversation is persistent here's what I
think is happening a domino effect is
occurring where there was a major
backlash to the sponsorship of Dylan
Mulvaney this started a metaphorical
fire for Anheuser-Busch a bunch of
people then jumped on it started talking
about it which created an opportunity
for more commentators to say okay let's
talk about it I'll put it this way I'll
be completely blunt I didn't really care
all that much and then I saw the video I
did and I got 1.5 million views and that
said two things to me one people really
care about this and I think it's as
simple as you've screwed with their beer
and now they are pissed off
the other thing I realized is you are
going to start to see commentators
capitalize on that and they're going to
make as much content about it as
possible because people care which is
for me let's be honest a business
opportunity but that's ancillary more
importantly it's a culture War
opportunity if this is the Hill People
are willing to die on let's roll baby
and now we have news coming out leaks
photos about the VP and about her frat
parties information is being brought up
about Bud Light sales it's fair to say
this is more than just Bud Light this
thing that happened last week and no one
cares anymore because Bud Light has
ignored their their their base their
Market
and they've they've basically doubled
down on this they've pissed people off
and they've created a viral opportunity
for online commentators be it for or
against it the fact that Joe Rogan
talked about it whatever it is he said
all that did was throw more fuel into
the fire it's going to get more people
asking what is going on with this NY
they actually talked about that on the
episode they were like look at us we're
drinking Bud Light right now so it's
working like any news is good news but I
it's not uh you can actually trash
people with a lot of news about them too
um well the issue is for Bud Light if
they're already at the top the top
selling beer in the world they can only
go down so that yes yes bat press is bad
for them and before the Scandal broke
out their stock was spiking up like 10
and now it's flip and started going down
where comparable beverage brands are not
seeing that same thing I actually I I
have a couple different things to say
about it I'm of two different Minds
about it one Bud Light and
Anheuser-Busch will be fine and they're
going to be fine for for a very specific
reason well two specific reasons one
because the right does cannot can never
maintain a culture War fight at all I I
I I know they had a bad bad weekend but
I watched the NFL have bad ratings for a
precisely about oh 15 minutes when black
lives matter was taken a steaming dump
all over the flag and every person on
the right going they couldn't wait to
run social media and they're I'm done
forever and I'm done and NFL's racist
and I hate this place and I hate America
and like I said about 15 minutes later
they were all bragged oh did you see
that throw from Drew Brees it was
wonderful the right can never maintain
these things because they don't love
freedom as much as the Communists hates
Freedom that's one agreed two but light
Anheuser-Busch is going to be fine
because the truth is as many
organization has found it has found out
from financial institutions to sports
like the NBA to others you do not need
to appeal to a customer base anymore
that is an old way of thinking you need
to appeal to the regime and right now we
have a new religion in America we are
the US of gay now that is the regime I
don't care what you think of it whatever
lgbtq whatever everything revolves
around that now we have the Secretary of
State saying he's riding Saudi Arabia
every single day about gay rights we we
are in a time of insanity in the United
States of America from the Pentagon to
the Secretary of State to entertainment
that's all they care about so if
Anheuser-Busch has proven they're going
to be loyal to the new religion of the
US of gay they will eventually be okay
they will disagree uh the point is
they've lost five billion dollars their
stock is going down and so long as
people have two things the willpower
which I admit is lacking among people
who are anti-establishment to a great
degree but there's something more
important here
you see outside of the willpower there's
monetary incentive so it may be that
many people on the right don't have the
willpower within 15 minutes would be
cheering for you know whoever's throwing
the latest touchdown pass the issue for
Budweiser right now they're not going to
be able to overcome is that online
personalities are getting a major flood
of viewership from talking about this
it's not going to go away so long as I
could put out a video and get half a
million views just by saying Budweiser
and that's an opportunity we've not seen
before so I don't care about the money I
care about the fact that people will
watch it and then I can say don't forget
don't buy Budweiser and it's not just
that we're not asking people to go out
and register a hundred thousand voters
we're not asking everybody right now to
be Scott Pressler we do wish everybody
would be Scott Pressler but if we can't
get that the least we can get is oh yeah
next time you go to the store
um my Guinness buy buy buy
I don't even know what PBR old style or
something let me tell you why I disagree
with that you're not wrong but I
disagree with it yes we can hurt them
and we should and we and I hope we
maintain this but really what what
drives so many of these corporations now
is the major financial institutions
including the financial institutions of
the United States States government all
of which now are governed by all this
ESG lgbtq all this insane crap so yeah
let's say Anheuser Bush let's say the
right finally steps up and sticks with
something and please Lord let them stick
with something for the first time ever
and let's say they stop buying in these
Southern Distributors really cancel
these orders and people stop buying and
they stick with them they don't forget
about this which they're gonna but let's
just say for the for the sake of
argument they do not you know what
Anheuser-Busch will still have access to
endless capital from Wall Street and
Washington DC because they have paid
homage to the religion of the nation
they've paid homage to America's
religion oh yes it should it means
everything why do you think the NBA has
taken the entire gen duration the entire
generation and they've alienated an
entire generation of American young
people because no reason to do that they
made a bet that conservatives classical
liberals will do nothing about it that
you're right about but this is where
we're starting to see something actually
bigger happen where people for the like
we look we've seen uh the Nike boycotts
right and the funny thing is when Colin
Kaepernick took a knee or whatever and
the Nike sponsors him all of these
videos emerge of people burning their
gear and their socks and all that within
three years every single athlete took a
knee and if you didn't you were the odd
person out that was a defeat something
different happens after a week and over
a holiday weekend when people are
supposed to forget about it
Anheuser-Busch thought they could keep
their mouths shut and this would go away
and we're looking at now a week of their
stock dropping I'll take it and I won't
shut up about it because if we can keep
the pressure on and keep talking about
it eventually get to the point where it
doesn't matter if they have endless
Capital if the regional if the regional
stores and the rural stores say we're
not going to carry your product it's
become popular and it's hurting our
brand to carry it because people are
getting offended are are angry that
we're not involved in this you're going
to see Distributors kicking it back
you're going to see people like John
Rich saying he won't carry the product
anymore but John Rich didn't say you
know what I hereby stand on principle
and will ban Anheuser-Busch uni said he
said honestly over the past week people
stopped buying it started to pile up so
we got we got to figure something out if
they're not going to buy it I'm not
going to I'm not gonna order it because
I'm losing money
John Rich came out after Kid Rock and
after uh Travis Trent was just like hey
look nobody's buying it and if that's
what's really happening and we're seeing
videos of people in grocery stores
showing the Bud Light is all still there
and the Budweiser is also there and
other brands are gone and now we saw I
think even we saw Dan Crenshaw come out
and post a video about it earlier this
week more and more people are getting on
the meme and the trend of not drinking
Bud Light
they're down I think four points I mean
that's massive imagine if you invested
in Anheuser-Busch and you look after the
past week and you and you lost four
percent imagine if you were a
billionaire and what four percent could
actually mean at this point I'm sure
there are people calling up Bud Light
and being like look I'm not going to
scream and throw a fit over four percent
this is probably going to be temporary
but you got to tell me what you're doing
about this and the pressure is starting
to build thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time